after to mass shootings the president's
up to a tight script condemning a
culture that haunts America the shooter
in El Paso posted a manifesto online
consumed by racist hate in one voice our
nation must condemn racism bigotry and
white supremacy these sinister
ideologies must be defeated hate has no
place in America hatred warps the mind
ravages the heart and devours the soul
he shared in their grief calling for
changes to mental health laws but
critically not gun laws among the
flowers in our Paso is the little
details of lives left behind not
legislation on people's minds there is a
peaceful solemnity here more and more
people coming from both sides of the
border to pay their respects whatever
the president says or does it is what
they say to each other that matters the
most right now
Joe Sato is hugging his daughter a
little tighter today he was there as the
gunman opened fire I was ordering food
for us I paid came around the corner the
lady from the cashier to know your
number and that's when I heard cha-cha
shooting the shooting and when I looked
over my shoulder I saw the gun smoke
literally I was like maybe ten feet away
[Music]
as shots run out and people cowered
under tables Joe helped a group hide in
a kitchen
older people scared looking at me and
I'm like just don't say nothing
stay quiet call my wife and I just kept
seeing my kids I'm not gonna make it
better not some who saved others
couldn't save themselves
Jordyn aunt Rhonda was killed alongside
her husband Andre while shielding their
two-year-old baby Allen tie-rocks team
treated him that was really sad knowing
that child would be grown up growing up
without a parent I'm not sure he was
going to take care of that child I'm
sure aunt or someone will step in to
grant Aaron this child was so small I
mean the mom protected that baby what we
saw this week and unfortunately it was
massive tissue destruction because these
bullets when they hit the body they're
meant to implode which means they
flatten out and that causes more injury
to bone blood vessels nervous tissue
it's meant to kill there is solidarity
and defiance here but fear too with no
promise that it won't happen again
well Delia Lynch Sky News our Paso Texas